[Música]
el mundo ya conoce al Premio Nobel de
paz 2022 el encarcelado activista
bielorruso Álex de las organizaciones
Memorias de Rusia y la Ucrania
son los ganadores por su lucha por el
derecho a criticar al poder y denunciar
crímenes contra la humanidad según la
organización de Medicina forense de Irán
la causa de la muerte de la iraní
ocurría tras haber sido detenida por la
policía de la moral por presuntamente
utilizar mal su velón no se debió a
golpes sino una dolencia previa el
documento contradice la versión de la
familia ampliaremos desde Terán y la
tasa de desempleo en Estados Unidos cayó
en septiembre respecto a Boston Aunque
expertos consideran que la reserva
Federal necesita un estancamiento
laboral para no seguir subiendo las
tasas de interés y evitar caer en
recesión
Buenos días bienvenidos una nueva
emisión informativa de Franz 24 en
español Muchísimas gracias por
acompañarnos como todos los días soy
Santiago aristía y comenzamos con una de
las noticias que sin lugar a dudas está
marcando la jornada de hoy Y es que el
mundo ya conoce al Premio Nobel de paz
2022 hablamos de uno de los más
esperados de los que otorga el comité
Nobel noruego concede y nos lo y los
premiados fueron el bielorruso Álex
vialiansky también las organizaciones
Memorial de Rusia y la ucraniana center
por civil libertyes por su lucha por el
derecho a criticar al poder y denunciar
crímenes contra la humanidad
vialevski fue detenido en julio del año
pasado en medio de una campaña
gubernamental contra opositores y ha
seguido muy de cerca la represión por
parte del gobierno del presidente
Alexander lucasen con Memorial es una
iniciativa ciudadana surgida en los
finales de la unión soviética para
investigar crímenes aunque fue
suspendida tras la invasión de Rusia a
Ucrania Mientras que el centro para las
civiles ucraniano se dedica a investigar
de manera independiente y las
violaciones a los derechos humanos y a
combatir la corrupción de esta manera
recibieron el premio algunos de los
ganadores escuchemos
esta fue una noticia muy grande no la
esperábamos personalmente ni siquiera
sabía que nuestra organización había
sido nominada esto es un paso muy grande
para que el mundo sepa de nosotros sé
que la propaganda rusa tiene influencia
diciendo que los ucranianos están
abusando de otros ucranianos y rusos
pero todo el mundo democrático ha
reconocido el terror de la federación
rusa contra el pueblo y los territorios
ucranianos
vamos a conocer ahora en el siguiente
informe preparado por Jim Muñoz algunas
de las reacciones ante este premio que
llega en un contexto de muchísima
atención a nivel mundial con la guerra
en Ucrania marcando la agenda
internacional veamos
un premio Nobel de la Paz Al activismo
post soviético opositores rusos y
bielorrusos y Defensores de Derechos
Humanos ucranianos en kiev los
ciudadanos celebran el galardón para el
centro para las libertades civiles
Ucrania se ha ganado el respeto de la
comunidad internacional es señal y creo
que no será el último reconocimiento
como bien dice este señor el mundo Mira
a Ucrania Ya que ellos que hacen
oposición en Rusia Y belarús lo
demuestra el tuit de Enhorabuena del
presidente de Francia Emmanuel macron el
premio Nobel de la paz honra a los
defensores inquebrantables de los
Derechos Humanos en Europa artesanos de
la paz saben que pueden contar con el
apoyo de Francia distinta es la opinión
en belaruz después del premio para el
activista bielorruso Álex vialiavsky así
habló en Twitter el ministro de
exteriores anatoly glass
en los últimos años una serie de
decisiones fundamentales y estamos
hablando del premio de la paz del comité
del Nobel sean politizado tanto que
disculpe Alfred Nobel se revolcaría
atormentado en su tumba pero la
oposición no solo viene desde los
aliados de Rusia de forma sorpresiva mi
High lo puedo liak asesor del presidente
mercedeski protestó por el galardón
la organización rusa esto cuando el
presidente ucraniano borodimir zelenski
Era uno de Los favoritos de la gente
para recibir el premio
el comité del Nobel tiene una
interpretación interesante de la palabra
paz y los representantes de dos países
que atacaron a un tercero reciben un
premio Nobel juntos
el Nobel de la paz 2022 se ha anunciado
en el día del cumpleaños del presidente
ruso Vladimir Putin y después de que el
año pasado un periodista enemigo del
kremlin Dimitri murat también fuese
galardonado
y en Praga más de 40 líderes europeos se
reúnen en el que es el primer encuentro
de la comunidad política europea así se
abordaron temas Como por ejemplo la
seguridad la paz la energía y la
economía europea respecto de uno de los
temas que centran la atención de la
agenda a la presidenta de la comisión
europea Úrsula Wonderland aseguró que la
Unión Europea se ha preparado y ya tiene
una primera línea de protección para que
los mercados resistan Los Altos precios
de la energía y la inseguridad sobre el
suministro de gas
y según la organización de Medicina
forense iraní la causa de la muerte de
la iraní manzana mini ocurría tras haber
sido detenida por la policía de la moral
por presuntamente utilizar mal su velón
No sabría debido a golpes mientras
estaba bajo custodia sino a una dolencia
previa ampliamos esta información desde
veterano con nuestra corresponsal
Catalina Gómez Ángel
pasaron tres semanas antes de que el
gobierno iraní publicara esa
investigación que prometió desde el
primer momento para conocer las razones
del fallecimiento de maxam Mini esa
joven curda de 22 años que murió después
de haber sido capturada por la policía
de la moral enteran supuestamente por
llevar mal el vestimenta la vestimenta
islámica esta investigación ha sido
publicada por la organización de
forenses de Irán y ellos aseguran que
maxsa no murió como consecuencia de
ningún golpe como se había Asegurado por
algunas versiones incluida su familia
que dice que vio moretones en su piernas
y algunos doctores que también han
asegurado que la joven fue golpeada de
ellos dicen que esto viene de una
enfermedad de tiempo atrás de cuando
tenía 8 años una enfermedad del corazón
que pudo haber resurgido en ese momento
como consecuencia del estrés en ese
momento tuvo un paro cardíaco que le
impidió seguir respirando y lo que tuvo
grandes consecuencias no solamente en su
cerebro sino en múltiples órganos ellos
también dicen que esto se debe a una
deficiente reanimación respiratoria que
vivió en ese momento cuando estaba
detenida esta joven a estas horas las
redes iraníes se hacen preguntas sobre
realmente sí es cierta esta versión del
gobierno ya han tenido otras versiones
en los últimos días donde las
autoridades han querido Mostrar que
jóvenes que han fallecido lo han hecho
por razones que no tienen que ver con
las protestas mientras que su familia sí
denuncian que por ejemplo una de esas
jóvenes Sí fue golpeada o otra si se
encontraban las protestas a pasar de que
ellos quieren negarlo para mañana están
programadas nuevas manifestaciones en el
país Como protesta a esta muerte de maxa
Mini
hacemos con más noticias en Francia 24
vamos ahora a Francia porque
aproximadamente una de cada cinco
estaciones de servicio del país no está
siendo abastecida como debería y las
reservas estratégicas de petróleo
probablemente se utilizarán durante el
próximo fin de semana esto Dijo el
ministro de energía del país y mientras
tanto las huelgas en cuatro refinerías
de total energes continúan por décimo
día habríamos desde París con nuestra
periodista Erika olavarría
un 15% de las gasolineras en Francia
está teniendo problemas de suministro de
al menos un tipo de combustible así lo
confirmó el gobierno Esto está generando
colas pero también pérdida de tiempo de
los clientes mientras se encuentran una
gasolinera donde llenar el tanque de sus
vehículos la causa primero es el
descuento que hace la petrolera total de
20 céntimos a sus clientes esto se suma
a los 30 céntimos que da el gobierno por
lo mismo es esta empresa la que está
sufriendo más esta falta de combustibles
en los últimos días sus demandas han
aumentado un 30% sobre todo en el norte
y en el este del país y la otra causa es
la huelga que realizan los trabajadores
de total en tres de las cinco refinerías
que tiene la empresa en el país por
mejoras salariales ellos dicen que si la
empresa está ganando más dinero en este
momento debiera repartirlo también a sus
trabajadores Francia Entonces ha
comenzado a importar gasolina desde
Bélgica los Países Bajos y Luxemburgo
por lo mismo este fin de semana se va a
permitir el tránsito de camiones
cisterna por las algo que normalmente
está prohibido y también Francia ha
comenzado a tocar sus reservas
estratégicas 18 millones de toneladas de
combustible que representan el consumo
de Francia durante 90 días además las
autoridades han pedido los franceses que
no llenen el tanque sino es necesario
porque eso genera obviamente más demanda
y aseguran que la situación debe
normalizarse dentro de una semana vamos
ahora a Estados Unidos allí el
presidente es Joe biden anunció que
indultará las penas de los condenados a
nivel Federal por posesión de marihuana
una medida que no abarca sin embargo los
cargos vinculados con su producción o su
distribución se calcula que más de 7.000
personas podrían beneficiarse por la
orden que para muchos responde intereses
electorales desde el presidente y del
partido demócrata el informes de Manuela
Cano
un paso hacia la despenalización en
Estados Unidos el presidente Joe biden
anunció que indultará a los condenados
por delitos federales relacionados con
la posesión de marihuana en primer lugar
voy a perdonar todos los delitos
federales anteriores de Posesión simple
de marihuana hay miles de personas que
fueron condenadas previamente por
posesión simple y a las que se les puede
negar el empleo la vivienda o las
oportunidades educativas como resultado
mi indulto eliminará esta carga
la medida no cubre cargos relacionados
con la producción o posesión de
marihuana con la intención de
distribuirla y además aplica únicamente
a condenas federales sin embargo el
mandatario hizo un llamado para que los
gobernadores den el mismo paso hacia el
perdón de los delitos estatales para
muchos analistas se trata de una
decisión con fines electorales A pocas
semanas de unas elecciones de medio
término en las que los demócratas se
arriesgan a perder sus estrechas
mayorías legislativas es parte de una
batería de medidas y además de
legislaciones que el presidente ha ido
tomando enfocándose en grupos que yo
pienso que a los demócratas consideran
que son todavía gananciables en el marco
de la acumulación de apoyo electoral
creo que se ven forzados ante la nueva
crecida del costo de los combustibles
ante los nuevos efectos de las medidas
fijadas por la OPEP a improvisar algunas
medidas que tienden yo creo que a tocar
sectores electorales que en los cuales
el voto demócra se concentra en este
caso la población afroamericana la
legislación sobre el consumo y posesión
de marihuana en Estados Unidos está
cambiando rápidamente ya son 19 los
estados en los que su uso medicinal y
recreacional es totalmente legal El
último en añadirse al grupo fue
Connecticut en junio algunos estados
como Minnesota Missouri o Florida
aceptan su uso únicamente medicinal
mientras que esta sigue siendo ilegal en
Idaho Wyoming Kansas y Carolina del Sur
más noticias llegan desde Estados Unidos
ahora en materia económica porque la
tasa de desempleo en el país cayó en
septiembre al 3.5% desde el 3.7% del
pasado mes de agosto esto según el
departamento de trabajo que agregó
además que 5.8 millones de personas
están desocupadas las estadísticas
también muestran que en el noveno mes
del año los empleadores agilizaron su
nivel de contrataciones algunos
analistas consideran que el mercado
laboral continua resistencia a la subida
de las tasas de interés por parte de la
reserva Federal lo que podría Conducir a
que sigan aumentando en los próximos
meses y el Banco Central ha venido
elevando tasas en un esfuerzo por
controlar la inflación pero con el
riesgo de llevar en la economía a una
recesión para analizar este escenario
económico que atraviesa a Estados Unidos
o nos acompaña el economista Iván
Jiménez Iván Muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en France 24 en español bueno
cuando uno ve que el desempleo disminuye
cree que estemos ante una buena noticia
verdad Pero el mercado no piensa lo
mismo porque
creo que en este clima lo que está
tratando en realidad de hacer la reserva
para tratar de reflexionar al reflejarse
en el mercado laboral es controlar la
inflación y una de las formas de medir
ese control de la inflación es tratar de
desacelerar la demanda y a través de
ello impactar empleos lo que pasa es que
en esta vuelta no es un proceso de
tradicional económico lo que ha causado
gran parte de esa dislocación ha sido la
pandemia Y en este momento lo que
estamos viendo Es el vigor de la
reintroducción justamente de las
exigencias del consumidor en la economía
americana y lo otro es una saludable
economía en el clima laboral entonces lo
que una cosa Parece ser contraria a la
otra pero no necesariamente lo es en
este momento lo que está pasando Es que
la economía americana está demostrando
que quiere volver a la normalización Y
eso se está reflexionando reflejando a
de los números de empleo hablamos de la
reserva Federal estadounidense que está
tratando de frenar no la inflación
subiendo las tasas de interés para
moderar el consumo Es una medida
dolorosa para parte de la población pero
estando resultados desde su punto de
vista
creo que sí creo que si vemos algunas
algunas cifras de aceleración en la
inflación hemos bien hemos visto
moderación y lo otro es que aunque ha
habido un aumento que lo hemos
presenciado en Estados Unidos en la
fuerza laboral en la demanda en precios
de rubros básicos ya muchos de ellos ha
comenzado a desacelerar y lo tercero es
que gran parte de lo que hace la reserva
parte de las medidas que toma es mandar
un mensaje y creo que el mensaje que ha
sido elocuente es que va a ser todo lo
posible a su alcance de girar de un
mercado donde era el dinero libre y
gratuito a un mercado restrictivo donde
las reservas va a ser todo lo posible
para frenar
la tasa de aceleración de la economía y
eso es lo que debe hacer una reserva
Iván Jiménez Muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en France 24 llegamos al final
de esta emisión administración invitamos
a que sigan informándose en transmitir 4
y en 24.com
[Música]